ready and stretch it's literally so long
he came up in the camera you guys look
at this oh my god hey guys this is Inka
today I am gonna be making some super
stretchy hand-pulled noodles using only
four ingredients and hopefully by the
end of this video you'll also be able to
make it at home I feel like those videos
of people at restaurants doing that
really cool noodle pooling technique is
something that always blows up this
technique has been around for a long
time I know I've seen it a lot when I'm
in Taiwan so it's something that I've
always wanted to try and the best thing
about it too is that not only does it
look super amazing and really impressive
it also makes your noodle a lot tastier
you get that beautiful bounce that q
kunis that I I love saying it's always
about the QQ did a bit of research and I
found an easier way for us to all be
able to make it at home
using only some pantry items it is the
month of May it is a Pam there are no
better ways to celebrate them to make
some fresh handful noodles at home let's
get to noodle making all right so let's
talk ingredients first things first
you're gonna need some flour I'm just
using all-purpose flour you need some
water some salt some oil and that's it
now that we have everything ready and
off to the sides we can start making our
dough our new dough dough our new dough
dough
we're gonna start making our dough I
already measured out my flour there's
around 2 cups of flour in here I'm just
gonna slowly add my water and we need to
keep stirring while we combine these two
a little over 1/2 a cup if it's too dry
just add a little bit more water but
just make sure it's not too wet and then
before I forget I put in my salt that's
just about a teaspoon it was pretty much
there to help strengthen the gluten
which will also help make it stretch
away later at this point I have a rough
clump of dough roll up my sleeves I'm
just gonna go in with my hands it's
slowly coming together ready this is
honestly the most work you'll have to do
and we have our little ball of dough
we're gonna
meet this on the board we're just gonna
keep doing there's motion we're gonna be
doing this for a while giving this dough
a lot of love I'm sorry I sound so out
of breath the reason we need to keep
meeting this is because right now looks
kind of wrinkly it looks like when
you've been sitting in the bathtub for
too long we want this to be super super
smooth we want it to feel like this
dough has had days of the best skin care
so I'm gonna keep doing this for maybe
five to ten minutes we'll see what it
looks like after that time this is what
it looks like right now it is definitely
smoother but we still have some ways to
go I feel like the dough is getting a
little harder to work with what I'm
gonna do is just cover it with a wet
towel and let it chill for around 10
minutes and then continue kneading 10
members later this is what we have now
that it's a little more oh it's a lot
more pliable once you let your dough
relax a little
it's gonna be a lot more obedient a good
dough boy now it's already really smooth
I already get really excited about this
part this is our little dough boy this
is what it looks like smooth dough take
our last ingredient the oil I'm gonna
cover it up completely super important
it again will help make it more stretchy
later I'm gonna take a rolling pin
lightly coat it with oil just gonna roll
it out into a disc shape you can see
that it's super smooth it's looking
pretty good and what we're gonna do now
is actually slice it up brush it with
oil again coat our knife I'm not kidding
when I say this is my favorite part just
cut it into strips we're just gonna keep
on doing this that looks so good I can
already feel how soft it is
it is so beautiful super super tempting
I know to stretch it just like this
right now especially when it feels so
soft but hold on
transfer it over to a plate that I am
again going to cover with oil do a
little like puzzle fitting being really
careful oh my god it's paint on some
more oil we build it on a last brush of
oil basically we're giving it like a
little oil bath got the wonders it will
do for its stretchiness look at these
beautiful strips of dough what we're
gonna do now is actually cover it in
plastic wrap and this is really
important you have to let it sit for at
least two hours otherwise it's not gonna
work go do some work watch a show and
then we can do some noodle point it has
been quite some time here's our dough
whoa okay it's already super super
stretchy
make like a fake table hear the
struggles of a New York kitchen it is
noodle pooling time I am going to pick
up one of these strands and I'm just
going to gently press it down I like
eating wider noodles and that's why I'm
pressing it down already really stretchy
we're gonna turn this is amazing it
doesn't take too much effort for it to
already be super super stretchy just
keep on going and keep on a folding if
you want look at this
alright I'm getting a little too excited
one more time this is what we're
starting out with again gently press
that down stretch and slap
it's so long already this is like jump
rope noodle this is so much fun to do
we're gonna do one more it's fairly
small right now that is a noodle we have
a beautiful noodle hold it and do it
again this is what we started out with
and this is what we have now noodles for
days I have three really long noodle
strands there you go you guys look at
that you can totally do this too before
this all sticks together toss them into
this pot of salted water giving them a
quick stir right now it really just
looks like really thick and chewy
noodles so exciting alright so my
noodles are cooked usually I like to
rinse them in cold water to give them
that like QQ texture but we're just
gonna go right for it today I know I
said that noodle pooling was the best
part but come Orland let's be honest
like tasting it
best part lay it on there oh yeah you
guys it looks pretty legit gonna give it
a quick test to see the texture here I'm
having a lot of trouble because this
noodle is never-ending
that's the chewiness already so good but
obviously oh my god I'm getting a little
excited at this point it is already a
success the noodles are done super proud
of where we've come to from our little
dough baby I have a quick sauce that is
my go-to and then we can do a popper
taste test go ahead and dress this up
really quick just give me a few seconds
[Music]
so gorgeous it smells so good in here
and now I'm going to give it a stir
salivating like crazy right now tell me
this doesn't make you hungry
this looks almost exactly like what it
would be like if you ate outside at a
restaurant you feel that bounce that
it's supposed to have too much talk too
little eating when I tell you guys that
this is perfect I am not kidding sauce
aside even just the texture in itself
the flavor or that hard work you put in
it really pays off
also it's a really hard work if you're
having fun while doing it because I had
a lot of fun and again these numerals
were only made using four ingredients
you can totally do that to definitely
give it a try
have fun at home do with that amazing
noodle pool let me know if you do tag me
I am salivating again so I'm gonna stop
talking and I will see you guys next
time bye
[Music]